it's the most coveted calendar on the
planet but it's not one you can normally
buy in a bookstore
now all those annual additions have been
brought together in a single 600 page
edition together with previously
unpublished material for a special
anniversary publication to be a part of
family calendar is a very small
extraordinary and will experience in
fashion it's what all the women all the
girls dream to be once a model for
humanist girls we use the periodic
calendar the kind of goddesses of today
this is like really joining a club a
very exclusive club there in the making
imagery and art and something
collectible using the best people in the
world the calendar was launched in 1964
as a promotional tool for Italian tire
maker Pirelli it was then published more
or less on an annual basis but it was a
strictly limited edition with all copies
reserved for celebrities and top Pirelli
customers that exclusivity was
intensified because production costs
were kept under wraps the publication
became a collector's item
for experts such as Stephie schultz a--
director of renowned berlin photography
gallery camerawork there's much more to
Pirelli than stylish photos Cleve worked
continually on the quality and
exclusivity they also have the best
photographers of the day the result is a
piece of cultural history among the 36
photographers recruited over the years
most of them from the fashion world are
truly big names including Norman
Parkinson and Richard Avedon German
photographer Peter Lindbergh has done
two Pirelli calendars so did Californian
Herb Ritts Annie Leibovitz is one of the
rare female photographers Peru's Mario
Testino shot the 2001 calendar and
French fashion photographer Patrick
Demarchelier the 2008 edition and in
2011 fashion designer Karl Lagerfeld was
entrusted with the job
Clyde Arrowsmith shot two in a row in
the 1990s an absolute plum of a job for
the British photographer and painter
what makes it special photographer is
it's a dream the fact that they're going
to paid you a lot of money at that time
neither pay even more but the thing is
that you can you've got all the
facilities you know I mean it's like
when you shoot for Vogue
everybody will shoot for Vogue because
it's in vogue and everybody started to
shoot for Pirelli because it came an
icon and when you work for them you you
go to the desert for two and a half
weeks or three weeks and you go on
location you check all the costumes and
you can actually empower it with your
own vision as well as the art directors
vision of course who's commissioned you
and they do once they give it you they
let you go like a racehorse and you're
off each Pirelli calendar has its own
artistic theme in 1992 Aerosmith's
concept was Chinese zodiac signs
presented against the backdrop of a
desert in Spain the previous year
Aerosmith's calendar theme was heroines
but regardless of the concept the person
behind the camera and the exotic
locations the one key factor with the
Pirelli calendar is the glamorous women
for the first three decades most of the
models were not particularly well known
but since the mid-1990s a fair number of
those who posed have been famous
actresses like Sophia Loren or musicians
like Jennifer Lopez and then of course
there are the supermodels
some of them were still at the start of
their careers Naomi Campbell posed for
the 1987 Pirelli age just 16 Kate Moss
appeared for her first of three
calendars in 1994 it was best job ever
got to lie on a beach for half a day and
then took a few pictures and with her
and then met another donor beach didn't
feel like it's my home
it's the early ones were just really
like girls on the beach in like exotic
situation a bit like Sports Illustrated
is now you know like beautiful girls but
with topless lounging around on the
beach and then that was the sort of 60s
I didn't come in till the 90s and
whereas I said there was a women's
liberation movement and feminist
movement and they didn't want them to be
used as objects of sexy desire they
wanted it a bit more pirelli felt that
it should be a bit more sensual but
still have a artistic and creative
quality well nowadays everything has
become much more overtly sexy with like
a very stylish classy men's magazine our
ones were just toned down five decades
after its launch the cow as it's known
has reached legendary status
you